all right earlier in the program here in
miami we had a legendary miami dolphins
quarterback we gotta go to the legend of
the university of miami hurricane the
university heisman trophy winner number
one overall pick back in 1987. he's
vinnie testaferti yeah vinnie how are
you doing great guys how are you this
morning oh we're doing great great to
see you we go way back me and vinnie
vinnie's another guy i caught passes for
back in the day quarterback challenge
and he's the first quarterback for all
those out there that i ever witnessed to
throw the ball 80 yards then he could
throw the ball 80 yards like patrick
mahomes or a josh allen or maybe an
aaron rodgers right now but it was
unbelievable i remember like sitting
next to my dad i was like man my dad's
got like he's got a twinkie arm compared
to this guy
well i'm talking about that
that event you know i remember going i
was in hawaii and i remember your dad
saying hey we need to go work out so i
went with him and he took me through one
of his workouts and
i've never been so sore after workout
than i was when i went with him and he
really taught me what it was to work out
so how old were you at the time i think
that was 11 or 12 somewhere in that
range right 91 92. yeah there you go yep
and uh yeah vinnie was great to me as a
young kid another guy that you know just
made a great impression for how to act
as a professional athlete
and we were talking earlier vinnie about
your career and how long you were able
to play in the nfl unbelievable that you
actually suited up and played at the age
of 44 i mean people can't believe tom
brady is doing it at 42.
he still got two more seasons to catch
what you were able to do yeah you know
it becomes a whole different challenge
when you hit 40 and you know tom's done
a great job of that i think he still has
a few more good years left uh whether he
stays in new england i if he does do
that i hope he gets some uh some other
pieces that they need around him and
he'll be back to the old time brady as
as we know but uh if he moves on i
certainly understand that as well yeah
get it i mean i'm always curious like
you know yeah you win the heisman the u
you played for all these teams had a few
good runs with a few of them like but
who do people identify you with the most
and who do you identify yourself with
yeah you know i grew up in new york as a
jet for a childhood team of mine that i
followed and i really loved playing for
the jets it's probably where i have my
most success right so i would say it's
new york jets gotcha uh tampa bay is a
close second being that that was where i
was drafted out of college too uh love
love both teams right cities and like
the you do people bring up the you a lot
to you too all the time all the time
love being back in miami yeah i love
being back here obviously is a big part
of
my career and what i was able to
accomplish yeah
and you know we talked about you earlier
this year because you were the ravens
single season touchdown pass record
holder until this year with lamar
jackson right the very first year you
were that that common thread from the
cleveland browns to the baltimore ravens
95 into 96. looking back on that just
had to be one of the craziest moments of
your life wrapping up things in
cleveland and then taking the team to
baltimore yeah you know we started the
season out pretty well in in cleveland
that year and uh about a third of the
way through
they announced we were moving to
baltimore and uh you know our season
just went in the tank we went from i
think we were five and two to six and
ten i believe after the announcement uh
was made and
not till years later i saw a segment on
one of the the uh
the shows that they did on the 95 browns
and talking and interviewing players at
the time when they were there talking
about how they were
really distracted they were thinking
about their families moving where we're
going over i think and now i know why
the team didn't have the success i
thought we're going to have because my
total focus was hey i'm on to the next
game i don't care where we're going next
year let's
finish this year but
you know it was uh certainly a little
bizarre but
got to baltimore they embraced us it was
a lot of fun and
as you mentioned uh lamar jackson just
broke the touchdown record i believe
this past year and it was great to see
because of all the stuff that he's had
to put up with and people criticizing
the way he uh
was throwing the football would you have
ever thought sitting here in 2020 when
you were with cleveland and bill
belichick like that now
he's the greatest coach in the history
of football and it's like not even close
well yeah you play the what if game and
yeah you know what if we weren't moving
to baltimore what if we all stayed in
cleveland what would it have been like
right would it have been the uh new
england patriots in cleveland yeah i was
there right you know but you saw like
you saw the greatness in belichick at
that point in time well you started to
understand
you know from what you see now right and
compare it to then why he's great gotcha
um you saw how how detailed and
dedicated he was to getting his players
ready and uh the respect that he had of
the players the the respect that he gave
to the players yeah uh you know
a lot of the stuff we saw you guys don't
get to see uh as a fan um so
he's to me he's he i i still keep in
touch him i have the utmost respect for
bill belichick i'm always a big fan of
his right right and then you had the
time with parcells with the jets that
you guys were on the doorstep you had
the ten nothing lead i think it wasn't
happening denver in denver against kyle
shanahan's dad mike and uh
very close with bill parcells to getting
get into a super bowl yeah well bill's
my all-time favorite coach uh you know i
again greatest respect for coach
parcells i love playing for him um i
love that he uh
had a big impact on my career and and me
being able to play for as long as i did
so uh i can't say a bad thing about
coach brussels even though he was pretty
tough on quarterbacks as your dad that's
all i want to say give us a story
because dad's got you know nine million
stories what's like your number one bill
parcells no
the one thing that that that i can share
with you is during a game and we're
backed up on our own 20 and and the
team's running out and he kind of grabs
me and he says now listen we're going to
throw it on first down and don't throw
an interception
just like that no four-letter words huh
yeah well
i'm ad-libbing a little bit anyway so we
get out there what do you think happens
i throw an interception
i come off the field and he's about to
get in my face and i'm like coach don't
you ever tell me to not do i said tell
me to throw a touchdown a completion but
don't tell me not to throw an interest
and i think from that day on is where i
gained his respect and from that day on
is where i really had a a pretty good
season i only threw seven interceptions
that year uh it was it was at the time i
think the highest touchdown to
interception ratio
um
uh prior to today's game yeah anyway
yeah yeah that's that's amazing yeah
that's not what you want to hear when
you walk out in the field
you know what i think parcells i think
sometimes he needles because he wants to
wake that thing up yeah he woke up in
you and then it's like all right my work
here is done yeah before our work is
done you got to tell us about what you
got going on with straight talk wireless
yeah so i'm partnering with straight
talk wireless which is a prepaid no
contract uh service
last year during the super bowl we had
fans streaming the game uh within over
seven and a half million devices which
was up 20 from 2018 so we're hoping to
get more fans to do that this year right
and if they're looking for more
information they can either
uh go to exclusively at walmart in store
online or just go to straighttalk.com to
find out all the information that they
need
to find out about it yeah that sounds
pretty cool yeah i mean i guess if
you're a millennial and you just want to
lift through your phone and your
computer you could do this and watch
just about whatever you want yeah well
seven and a half million people say that
yeah they can do it yeah that's
hopefully they watch us on the csn yeah
hopefully they've been watching
hopefully they've been watching this all
morning more hours almost done
congratulations on your career we'll be
back and wrap up this wednesday edition
of pft live right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports